[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und claus kleber
guten abend spät zu spät man wird
darüber streiten wie viel zu spät sind
entscheidungen gefallen heute auf der
einen schiene im bundestag auf der
anderen schiene in der runde der länder
chefs und chefinnen ergebnis nummer eins
im bundestag die pandemische notlage von
nationaler tragweite ist nächsten
donnerstag offiziell vorbei was
angesichts der aktuellen zahlen wie ein
böser scherz aussieht wird jedenfalls
teilweise aufgefangen durch ergebnis
nummer zwei ein neues pandemie gesetz
das mehr als bisher entscheidungsmacht
in die 16 bundesländer und die landtage
dort verteilt ob das reicht war und
bleibt umstritten
wenn sich der noch nicht bundeskanzler
spd und die noch bundeskanzlerin cdu im
bundestag nicht verstehen gehen sie halt
raus frau gestern und herr morgen
versuchen füreinander verständnis zu
finden und es dann öffentlich zu zeigen
bei ihren parteien läuft es genau
andersrum obwohl allen derselbe text
vorliegt verstehen mehrheit alt und
mehrheit neu das geänderte
infektionsschutzgesetz komplett
gegensätzlich
der rat bars und clubs das sind die
hotspots das sind die pandemie treiber
die müssen geschlossen werden können
nach ihrem gesetzentwurf wird das
zukünftig nicht möglich sein der sagt
großveranstaltung die müssen abgesagt
werden können nach ihrem gesetzentwurf
wird das nicht möglichkeit sein das was
sie hier streuen sind falschinformation
diskotheken und clubs können nach der
rechtslage die wir auf den weg bringen
von den ländern geschlossen werden alles
was sie hier so berührend ist falsch
dass die so genannte epidemische lage
von nationaler tragweite
die gesundheitsminister spahn vor
anderthalb jahren eingeführt hat nächste
woche enden soll hält die neue ampel
mehrheit nicht für eine lockerung im
gegenteil auch die praktisch relevanten
maßnahmen wie beispielsweise
2g oder 3g oder die hygiene konzepte mit
personen über grenzen standen vorher auf
rechtlich tönernen füßen wir stellen sie
jetzt auf rechtssichere füße und ist ein
fortschritt in der pandemie bekämpfung
meine damen und herren
deutlich mehr als wir bisher hatte home
office oder drei gehen damit schützen
wir die arbeitsplätze wir schützen den
öffentlichen verkehr mit 3 4 in den
zügen natürlich ist es kontrollierbare
mit stichproben wie man das eben macht
in solchen fällen witzig und giftig die
debatte auch die linke wirft allen drei
ampel parteien mangelnde verlässlichkeit
vor aber vor allem einer organisierte
verantwortungslosigkeit
was haben sie eigentlich den grünen und
der spd in den tee getan bei den
koalitionsverhandlungen weil die
richtlinienkompetenz lichkeit auch bei
ihnen
empört gibt sich auch heute die afd von
der sich ein gutes dutzend abgeordnete
weigern einen geimpft gewesen oder
getestet nachweis vorzulegen und deshalb
nur auf der tribüne teilnehmen dürfen 2g
und 3g dienen nicht dem
gesundheitsschutz 2g und 3g dienen dazu
die bürger mit massivem druck zu
willigen untertanen zu erziehen und da
machen wir als afd nicht mit der
gesetzentwurf zur änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
ist der erste den die ampel gegen
cdu/csu durchsetzt aber schon morgen im
bundesrat braucht man sich wieder
aus solchen debatten dann die
wesentlichen fakten herauszulesen ist so
kompliziert wie die pandemie lage
insgesamt und auch wieder verirren uns
mal im zahlen dschungel am montag galt
es zu zeigen wie viel mehr ungeimpfte
zur belastung der krankenhäuser
beitragen als kämpfte wesentlich mehr
nämlich das stimmt leider haben wir in
der überschrift bezugsgröße falsch
gewählt und am ende sah die grafik immer
noch beunruhigend aus aber harmloser als
die wahre lage dafür bitten wir um
entschuldigung
details stehen auf heute.de annegret
oster fast jetzt kernpunkte des neuen
infektionsschutzgesetzes zusammen heute
im bundestag beschlossen
geht es nach spd fdp und den grünen
gelten ab dem 25 november folgende neue
corona maßnahmen 3g am arbeitsplatz wer
bei der arbeit mit menschen kontakt hat
muss geimpft oder genesen sein oder sich
testen lassen und zwar täglich die
rückkehr zur home office pflicht wo
immer es geht soll von zu hause aus
gearbeitet werden eine testpflicht den
pflegeheimen und kliniken für
beschäftigte und besucher und 3g in
öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln offen
allerdings ist wie das kontrolliert
werden soll
heftiger schlagabtausch im bundestag
denn zusätzlich zu den neuen regeln
sollen einige besonders einschränkende
maßnahmen künftig nicht mehr möglich
sein
bundesweit soll es keine ausgangssperren
mehr geben
umfassende schul und kita schließungen
fallen weg es soll keine
reisebeschränkungen mir geben genauso
wenig wie generell flächendeckende
schließungen und verbote
gottesdienste demonstrationen und andere
versammlungen soll nicht mehr umfassend
untersagt werden ob das gesetz morgen
den bundesrat passiert ist offen klar
ist nur das virus kennt keine
parteigrenzen
den unionsgeführten bundesländern haben
die beschlüsse auch nicht gereicht sie
wollten noch eine handvoll weitere
kraftvolle werkzeuge im kasten und
drohten damit die gesamte
gesetzesinitiative der ampel parteien
morgen im bundesrat scheitern zu lassen
wenn sie diese zusatz werkzeuge nicht
bekommen und dann gab es am nachmittag
die runde von länder chefs und chefinnen
mit kanzlerin und ihrem mutmaßlichen
nachfolger und ließ dann erstmal ein
bisschen luft aus dem konflikt wie
haltbar das ist fragen wir gleich den
noch neuen ministerpräsidenten von nrw
nach dem bericht über die beschlüsse von
frank buchwald
es hat natürlich länger gedauert mehr
als vier stunden haben sie beraten denn
die lage ist dramatisch immerhin darin
sind merkel und die ministerpräsidenten
sich heute einig die lage ist
hochdramatisch und es wird jetzt sehr
darauf ankommen dass schnell gehandelt
wird das konsequent gehandelt wird das
besser kontrolliert wird und dann wird
man beobachten müssen ob wir die dynamik
damit stoppen oder zumindest reduzieren
können kernpunkt der einigung ein
stufenplan als maßstab soll künftig die
hospitalisierung rate gelten also wie
viele corona infizierte ins krankenhaus
müssen bei stufe 3 können die behörden
eine zweig regelung anordnen dürfen nur
noch geimpfte und genesen in restaurants
oder museen
bei stufe 6 gilt zweig plus dann
brauchen auch geimpfte aktuelle tests
bei stufe neun sondern auch kontakt
beschränkungen möglich sein ein
genereller lockdown jedoch nicht
unionsregierte länder hatten sich mehr
gewünscht vollen dem kompromiss nun aber
wohl doch zustimmen und zwar wichtig
dass wir heute eine zusage vom bund
erhalten dass der instrumentenkasten das
des infektionsschutzgesetzes
spätestens mitte dezember evaluiert wird
diese zusage haben wir heute vom
bundesfinanzminister erhalten nach einer
blockade morgen im bundesrat sieht es
damit nicht mehr aus ein erfolg für olaf
scholz
ich bin sehr froh darüber dass wir jetzt
eigentlich in einer situation sind wo
gesellschaftliche konsens die auch
politik werden und zwar schnell und
zügig möglich sind die man sich vor
einem jahr und vor einem halben jahr
nicht hätte vorstellen können so soll am
arbeitsplatz eine 3g regelung gelten
zugang nur für geimpfte genesene und
getestete arbeitgeber sollen kostenlose
tests anbieten für beschäftigte in
pflegeheimen könnte eine impfpflicht
kommen 3g dann auch in öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln am ende so hofft die
politik ließen sich dann mehr menschen
impfen die impfquote liege immer noch
viel zu niedrig es liegt nicht daran
dass es zu wenig aufklärung gegeben hat
in den letzten monaten zu wenig werben
zu wenig impfmöglichkeit zu wenig
infrastruktur zu wenig geld zu wenig
impfstoffe oder zu wenig
entschlossenheit ist nicht der grund
sondern der grund ist dass es zu viel
egoismus und zu viel gleichgültigkeit
gibt
noch aber sind nicht alle dieser
regelungen gesetzes wird nun auch die
parlamente ankommen den bundestag aber
je nach kurvenlage auch die landtage
der ministerpräsident von nordrhein
westfalen ist auch vorsitzender der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
sie heute mit der kanzlerin sagt er in
schönen guten abend herr wüst sogenannte
kleber werden die von der union
mitregierten länder das neue gesetz
jetzt morgen durch den bundesrat lassen
ist die kuh wieder runter die sie
gestern abend aufs eis gestellt haben
wir haben heute eine sehr erfolgreiche
gemeinsame sitzung der
ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidenten mit der
bundeskanzlerin gehabt und ein starkes
erstes paket verabredet mit dem ziel
unsere menschen gut zu schützen in
dieser schwierigen phase der pandemie
und weil sie darin auch verabredet haben
die uns fehlen die nach wie vor
fehlenden maßnahmen genau zu evaluieren
das maßnahmenpaket genau anzuschauen bis
spätestens mitte dezember werden wir am
morgigen tag im bundesrat zustimmen
können das heißt sie müssen damit
rechnen dass die maßnahmen jetzt doch
nicht so wirken und sie mitte dezember
in der situation sind wo die infektionen
dermaßen galoppiert dass sie zusätzliche
werkzeuge noch bau wir hätten gern und
das war kern der kritik der
unions-bundestagsfraktion auch heute im
bundestag einen größeren werkzeugkasten
gehabt um die menschen besser zu
schützen das ist ein schwerer fehler in
dieser situation der 65.000
neuinfizierten an einem tag zu erklären
die epidemische lage sei vorbei das ist
glaube ich unstreitig ja wir hätten
gerne mehr instrumente in werden genannt
werden oder werden sie zu schlagt ihn zu
reagieren dann darf man jetzt nicht aus
parteipolitischen gründen am ende
blockieren welches werkzeug fehlt ihnen
speziell in den kasten jetzt will ich
ihnen gerne verraten herr kleber wenn
wir in einer situation wie
beispielsweise jetzt in sachsen oder
beispielsweise in teilen von bayern
große blaulicht transporte sehen wo
viele viele patienten durchs ganze land
verlegt werden müssen weil die
krankenhäuser über das limit gegangen
sind dann kann ich mir schlecht
vorstellen dass dann in den kneipen
munter weiter normal
und im moment wirklich sein also doch
jetzt gerade in 60 tagen zu schließen
und das ist einer der punkte die da
fehlt das passt nicht das heißt im
moment nach der jetzigen beschlusslage
können sie kneipen auch bei extrem hohen
infektionszahlen nicht schließen das ist
das was eben nicht geht man kann eine
einzelne kneipe schließen wenn da
irgendwas besonderes ist aber in einer
region die große probleme hat kann man
nicht sagen jetzt machen wir mal als
erstes alle kneipen zu und das ist ein
ding das wir kritisiert haben und das
ist teil der dinge die wir jetzt auch
gemeinsam verabredung von heute mit olaf
scholz genau beobachten werden ob wir
nicht solche zusätzlichen instrumente
wirklich brauchen die neue mehrheit im
bundestag war an der stelle nicht bereit
nachzubessern an anderen stellen wohl
das muss man fairerweise
konstatieren und heute kam in der
gemeinsamen sitzung der
ministerpräsident ministerpräsidenten
mit der kanzlerin und olaf scholz die
zusage dazu schriftlich festgehalten wir
evaluieren ob der instrumentenkasten
reicht oder nicht bestätigen es zum
wiedersehen mit der bei der nächsten
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz am 19
dezember da wird natürlich jetzt auch
wieder etwas ganz wichtiges so auf die
längere bank geschoben gestern abend hat
herr wieder in einer viel beachteten
rede dramatisch wie nie zuvor die lage
geschildert und hat gesagt wir kommen
auf jeden fall zu spät von den 60.000
plus die sich heute als infiziert
herausgestellt haben werden hunderte
sterben und wenn die beschlüsse den sie
heute gefasst haben vor acht wochen
gefasst worden wären als sämtliche
fachleute das schon forderten dann
würden hunderte von diesen menschen in
zukunft weiterleben können machen sie
sich in dem kontext jetzt ganz
persönlich auch mal vorwürfe ich habe ja
schon vor 14 tagen gefordert dass eine
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
zusammentreten soll das war dann hoch
strittig das hat auch zu verstimmungen
auf unserer seite geführt dass die
spd-seite dazu nicht willens war jetzt
sind wir heute endlich zusammen gekommen
und wir haben auch ordentliche
ergebnisse hingekriegt zweig
flächendeckend bei weitere entwicklungen
zweig plus und mit zustimmung der
landtage weiteres zudem die impfpflicht
für gesundheitsberufe etwas das vor
wenigen wochen noch nicht möglich
gewesen ist insofern wird jetzt schon
entschlossen gehandelt das heißt sie
machen sich wegen des samens in den
letzten monaten keine vorwürfe das
größte versäumnis liegt bei denen die
sich nicht haben impfen lassen ja auch
die politik hätte sicherlich vieles
besser machen können an vielen stellen
in dieser pandemie aber wir sind alle
davon ausgegangen in dem moment als die
impfstoffe da waren und der run auf die
impfstoffe los gegen dass ich viel viel
mehr menschen impfen lassen in einigen
teilen deutschlands sind gerade mal die
hälfte der menschen geimpft und wir
haben eine pandemie die nicht geimpften
das ist das große problem gerade nun hat
sich herausgestellt dass weniger die
vorschriften das problem sind als die
fehlenden kontrollen wie viel tausend
ordnungskräfte hat ihr großes bundesland
nordrhein westfalen jetzt bereit stehen
um konsequent überall zur überprüfung
und damit klar zu machen hier wird kein
spaß gemacht ja da haben sie vollkommen
recht das ist das große thema die
kontrolle ich werde morgen nachmittag
mit den kommunalen spitzenverbänden
zusammenkommen weil wir können das nur
gemeinsam mit allen staatlichen ebenen
umsetzen das ist ein wichtiges thema wir
haben uns in nordrhein westfalen schon
vor diesen tagen hier in den berliner
debatten verabredet deutlich höhere
bußgelder einzuführen wenn
beispielsweise ein wird nicht
kontrolliert dann bis zu 5000 euro es
muss schmerzhaft sein es muss jedem klar
sein es geht um leben und tod es geht um
die gesundheit von menschen es ist kein
spaß mehr danke schön herr
ministerpräsident und noch einen guten
ab dann gehen wenn also alles so gut
geht wie es jetzt noch gehen kann dann
soll das heute der tag gewesen sein der
die vierte welle unter kontrolle bringt
dazu ein kommentar von peter frey nein
dieser machtwechsel in corona zeiten ist
nicht geglückt überlastete kliniken und
die vielen toten täglich zeigen dass die
alte wie die voraussichtlich neue
regierung es monate lang versäumt haben
das land zu schützen die kanzlerin hat
recht es ist absurd die epidemische
notlage jetzt auslaufen zu lassen aber
wo war eigentlich ihr machtwort als
gesundheitsminister sparen genau das vor
einem monat forderte
wieso hat sie in wahlkampfzeiten oder
dann geschäftsführend mit vizekanzler
scholz eine kraftvolle booster kampagne
nicht zur chefsache gemacht merkels
respektable kanzlerinnen geschichte
endet mit einem folgenschweren
versäumnis und bei der ampel ist der
anfang nicht besser wochenlang hat sie
sich zur selbstfindung zurückgezogen
stadt rasch in der vierten corona welle
verantwortung zu übernehmen sie hat sich
dem druck der fdp gebeugt maßnahmen wie
ausgangssperren und flächendeckende
schließungen von geschäften schulen und
kindergarten ganz grundsätzlich vom
tisch zu nehmen das ist angesichts der
galoppierenden
infektionszahlen töricht unser staat
schreibt jedem autofahrer vor einen
sicherheitsgurt zu tragen schützt also
unvernünftige vor sich selbst das darf
ja muss er erst recht in einer
systemischen gesundheitskrise tun umso
mehr weil es eben auch und vor allem um
den schutz der anderen geht es ist jetzt
zeit zu sagen impfverweigerer jetzt
reicht's querdenker trotzige esoteriker
sie leben ihren eigensinn auszulasten
besonders gefährdete und des
krankenhauspersonals jedes unfallopfer
oder herzinfarkt patienten die an bett
auf der intensivstation brauchen zu
lasten aber auch all derjenigen die sich
ganz einfach auf den nächsten
weihnachtsmarkt gefreut haben wer
solidarität verweigert zerstört das
gemeinwesen das aber muss der staat
jetzt vor allem schützen mit allem was
dafür nötig ist
die meinung von chefredakteur peter frey
was die an der front der medizin von den
beschlüssen heute halten fragt na sein
könnte mir professor gernot marx im
update um 0 uhr 30 und ihr nachrichten
jetzt von den kunden aus im konflikt mit
belarus um die migranten an der grenze
zu polen hat bundesinnenminister
seehofer in warschau klar gestellt es
sei eine falsche meldungen aus belarus
dass deutschland bereit seit 2000 der
menschen aufzunehmen gegenüber
innenminister kaminski lobte seehofer
die bemühungen polens zur abwehr der
organisierten migrationsbewegung aus
belarus der außen grenzschutz polens
diene allen in der eben vor allem
deutschland in der grenzregion haben
weiterhin tausende migranten aus einige
hundert zogen in notunterkünfte etwa 400
iraker flogen wieder in ihre heimat
zurück
die korona krise hat die bundesagentur
für arbeit bislang 52 milliarden euro
gekostet größter posten waren 24
milliarden euro kurzarbeitergeld
in der spitze sei an einem tag so viel
ausgezahlt worden wie im gesamten jahr
2009 10 so der ba vorstand zudem haben
gewerkschaftsnahe wissenschaftlerinnen
festgestellt dass die korona hilfspakete
frauen weniger zugute kommen als männern
so gebe es zum beispiel für millionen
frauen in mini-jobs kein
kurzarbeitergeld
in der korona masken affäre der
csu-politiker nüßlein und sauter sieht
das oberlandesgericht münchen den
tatvorwurf der bestechung und
bestechlichkeit als nicht erfüllt an
auch der korruptionsverdacht aufgrund
ihrer parlamentarischen tätigkeit habe
sich nicht bestätigt gegen diese
entscheidungen kündigte die
generalstaatsanwaltschaft münchen
beschwerde beim bundesgerichtshof an
nüßlein mittlerweile aus der politik
ausgeschieden soll für die vermittlung
von masken geschäften einen hohen
sechsstelligen betrag erhalten haben
sauter über 1,2 millionen euro der
frühere kanzler österreichs sebastian
kurz hat seinen schutz vor
korruptionsermittlungen verloren das
parlament in wien folgte dem votum eines
zuständigen ausschusses und hob
einstimmig seine immunität auf der
heutige ovp fraktionschef war anfang
oktober nach vorwürfen der untreue
bestechung und bestechlichkeit als
regierungschef zurückgetreten kurz weist
alle vorwürfe zurück
in zwei bundesländern österreichs wird
angesichts dramatisch steigender corona
zahlen ab nächsten montag ein strikter
lockdown gelten auch für geimpfte und
genesene die landeschefs von
oberösterreich und salzburg kündigten an
die maßnahme auch unabhängig von
landesweiten bestimmungen durchzusetzen
die sieben tage in studenzen der beiden
an bayern grenzenden bundesländer lagen
zuletzt bei über
1.500
das einstmals so stolzen erzbistum köln
wird derzeit wegen der furchtbaren
verfehlungen mit sexueller gewalt an
kindern statt von kardinal woelki von
einem apostolischen
administrator geleitet eingesetzt nach
hochnotpeinlichen untersuchungen durch
päpstliche visitatoren heute am
europäischen tag des schutzes von
kindern vor sexuellem missbrauch rief
der päpstliche administrator zu einem
bußgottesdienst
erwartet sich dafür in den staub wie nie
zuvor bezeichnete sich selbst als chef
der täter organisation erzbistum köln
das hat alles nicht gereicht dominique
müller rosell berichtet die gräben sind
für manche betroffene so tief geworden
dass schon die form eines gemeinsamen
gottesdienstes nach kirchlichem ritual
einfach nicht mehr ging
es ist ihnen ernst mit der puzzle will
dieser gottesdienst zeigen so ernst dass
das leid der betroffenen heute auf der
ganz großen bühne stattfinden soll im
kölner dom etwa das leid und die angst
eines jungen in einem kinderheim den ein
priester über jahre hinweg regelmäßig
vergewaltigte vorgetragen in form eines
liedes
[Musik]
und trotzdem oder gerade auch wegen
dieser demonstrativen bühne sind viele
betroffene der einladung heute nicht
gefolgt sondern protestieren davor
inszenierung eine fast erfen sie dem
bistum vor vor allem weil auf dieser
bühne heute eben nicht etwa kardinal
woelki oder andere buße tun sondern ein
unbescholtener
selber macht der weihbischof steinhäuser
das ist jemand der keine einzige
pflichtverletzung auf seiner liste
stehen hat dh die anderen sind nicht da
und der steinhäuser muss die iki die
guitar byd mit den betroffenen machen
das ist wiederum verschieben von
verantwortung und das ist klassisch vor
allen dingen in köln so bleibt im dom
die buße heute recht allgemein gehalten
wir knien vor dir barmherziger gott
und bitten um vergebung und genügt doch
manchen den betroffenen peter brinkmann
henseler etwa der das lied zu beginn des
gottesdienstes über seine erfahrungen
als vergewaltigte junge in kinderheim
geschrieben hat
ich bin der meinung dass ein schritt
gegangen worden ist wo auch betroffene
langsam aber sicher für sich die ruhe
finden ein schuldeingeständnis der
institution aber eben nach wie vor
keines der handelnden personen ihnen
gegenüber sagen die kritiker dafür
wollen sie wieder statisten sein in
einem gottesdienst in dem sie sowieso
nichts zu essen haben noch können sie in
solch allgemeiner form vergeben und
bleiben lieber fern
auch ich kann mich hier hinstellen
gesagt ich habe fehler gemacht das tut
mir alles leid aber ich muss bekennen
was ich falsch gemacht habe und das
fehlt mir total also dass wir das
allererste mal dass die die
verantwortung tragen ihre fehler so wie
sie gemacht haben auch einsehen und
eingestehen und das ist bis heute nicht
geschehen so spaltet heute der
bußgottesdienst die betroffenen ruhe
finden die allermeisten nicht
noch viel zu tun nachrichten noch einmal
von gundula gause
der stahl und industriekonzern
thyssenkrupp treibt seinen umbau
erfolgreich voran mit einer milliarde
euro überschuss rechnet die
vorstandsvorsitzende märz für das neue
geschäftsjahr das wäre nach den
verlusten der vergangenheit eine
trendwende frank bethmann eine riesige
herausforderung für das
traditionsunternehmen ist die grüne
transformation
thyssenkrupp versucht bei der
stahlerzeugung vor allem weniger kohle
einzusetzen weniger kohle weniger co2
doch das bringt für die umwelt noch viel
zu wenig um die sehr energieintensive
stahlerzeugung klimaneutral umzustellen
braucht es ganz andere verfahren braucht
es wasserstoff und ökostrom bei
thyssenkrupp firmiert dieses geschäft
mit anlagen für die wasserstoff
herstellung unter dem namen the floor 1
engineers thyssenkrupp betrachtet sich
als technologieführer doch vor 20 25 ist
aus dieser produktion kein grüner stalin
wirklich nennenswerten mengen zu
erwarten zukunftsmusik also die die
aktie aber treibt seit tagen bereits
auch heute wieder über 6 prozent die
börse sieht im grünen stahl eine
riesenchance für die europäische
stahlindustrie verloren gegangen den
boden wieder gutzumachen gleichzeitig
vertuschen krupp immer noch auf
sparflamme der stellenabbau geht weiter
bislang hat der stahlkocher 7800 jobs
abgebaut bis 20 23 24 sollen es
insgesamt 12.000 sein der konzern ist
also noch immer mittendrin in der
transformation nicht nur in der grünen
doch die wird maßgeblich darüber
entscheiden wie erfolgreich das
traditionsunternehmen in zukunft noch
sein wird frank bethmann vielen dank
das buch von grünen co chefin bair borg
wird nicht mehr gedruckt und die e book
ausgabe sofort aus dem verkauf genommen
der einstigen kanzlerkandidatin war
vorgeworfen worden teile der publikation
abgeschrieben zu haben für die von
berbalk angekündigte überarbeitung des
buches fehlte im wahlkampf und in den
andauernden
koalitionsverhandlungen der raum ließ
sie über den verlag mitteilen
vogel des jahres 2022 ist der wiedehopf
immer noch sein lebensraum durch
intensive landwirtschaft bedroht
erklärte der naturschutzbund und der
bayerische landesbund für vogelschutz
auch wegen seiner spektakulären
erscheinung sei der wiedehopf mit seinem
orange-roten gefieder gewählt worden und
noch eine meldung vom tennis
olympiasieger alexander zverev hat bei
den atp finals in turin das halbfinale
erreicht am samstag trifft er dort auf
topfavorit novak djokovic souverän
besiegte der weltranglisten dritte aus
hamburg den polen burkhard schmidt 6 zu
2 und 6 zu 4 bereits zehn mal trat
zverev gegen den weltranglisten ersten
djokovic an nur drei partien davon
gewann er gegen den serben zuletzt bei
den olympischen spielen im sommer
und nach dem wetter geht es bei uns
weiter mit maybrit illners runde politik
in alarmzustand kommt der lockdown für
ungeimpfte unter anderem gebraucht hat
ringo ring ertappt und hendrik strick
und morgen erwarten sie hier marietta
slomka und 1 wolf bis bald
[Musik]
guten abend wieso ist der november so
viel grauer als der oktober im oktober
ist bei nebel der boden waren vom sommer
die sonne steigt hoch hat noch kraft
nebel löst sich meist schon am frühen
vormittag auf novembertage sind merklich
kürzer und kälter die sonne steht tief
niebel hält sich je nach wetterlage c
wird es tagsüber ein bisschen wärmer
hebt bodennebel auch weil ab hochnebel
kann sich über tage halten besonders
wenn eine kalte sperrschicht die
inversion darüber liegt der trick gegen
schlechte laune ist simpel raus gehen
tagsüber bekommen wir trotz nebel
draußen 20 mal so viel licht ab wie mit
leuchtmitteln drinnen
und manchmal haben wir dann auf den
bergen eine solche fantastische
fernsicht über das nebelmeer auch heute
nacht ist es am alpenrand klar sonst
meist bedeckt und es fällt etwas regen
an der ostsee weht ein starker bis
stürmischer westwind unter den wolken im
norden bleibt es recht mild kalt wird es
dagegen an den alpen mit minus 3 grad
morgen liegen die höchsttemperaturen in
süddeutschland meist bei einstelligen 5
bis 9 grad im norden sind es 10 bis 13
grad und auch morgen wird wieder für
viele ein sehr trüber tag mit kräftigem
westwind an der ostsee etwas sonne an
der nordsee leichtem nieselregen nur an
den alpen und auch auf den
schwarzwaldhöhen zeigt sich die sonne an
diesem wetter ändert sich auch am
samstag wenig ab sonntag wird es dann
von norden deutlich kälter schön aber
noch